the Joe Rogan experience well also
Barnard developed this insane discipline
while in prison that the hardships of
prison were so awful the feeling of
being locked up in contained that he
[ __ ] up his life he was so bound and
determined to become something special
that mean he's so disciplined
well even beyond that like he opened up
his eyes and he looked at the landscape
and he realized that most fighters are
not disciplined most fighters they like
the idea of being a champion they like
the idea of winning you know
championships and what that brain is not
just the championship of what the
championships and the money brings the
ladies that you know the party and all
the stuff and he said I'm gonna do it a
different way like these guys are out
gaining weight 20 pounds in between
fights I'm gonna live like a Spartan he
under he got the revelation and he just
stuck to it yeah he ate clean he lived a
clean line and he fought so disappear
yeah he fought so smart he was one of
the best defensive fighters ever just
and people didn't like that style man he
would pop you and grab you pop you and
grab me and people get frustrated they
would get out of composure and they
would start doing the things that maybe
they shouldn't have done and then he
would capitalize on those things I
remember when he fought Trinidad man I
mean oh that was fight these try that
was a killer and I love Tito I do too I
mean he was a killer I got a chance to
see Tito fight live in Vegas once was
amazing but when Bernard started putting
it on him I was like wow this is first
of all you this is like a legitimate
middleweight fighting guys really a
welterweight and this is also a really
special fighter who just figures people
out he fought Tito in New York City and
Madison Square Garden which is his
little Puerto Rico yes like you know I
think it was the week of the Puerto
Rican Day Parade lights and previously
to that fight in Puerto Rico Bernard
Hopkins took the Puerto Rican flag threw
it down caused him melee had to run out
of there get snatched out of the arena
wherever they were having a press
conference get thrown on the plane like
the the beef was real oh yeah and to be
able to like like perform under that
kind of pressure
unreal one of my favorite fights it's
when he was running away from the crowd
in Puerto Rico you realize like oh my
god he's on his own here like literally
people are trying to kill him but what
what's even crazier is he knew that was
gonna happen
like he knew okay this is good right
having a three to one threw the flag
down and it was on oh man but it worked
first of all it got so many people to
pay attention you gotta fight yeah and
then too it got you know it got Tito
emotional if he lost that fight he was
back to the back of the bus
if he wins the fight which he did he
moves on to become great yeah he moves
on to greatness you know it's
interesting when you watch his style as
well that very technical very
disciplined style versus ROI style which
was so athletic and explosive and very
unusual with that lead left hook that he
would fire off more than a jab I mean
Roy had a crazy style and then will you
watch Roy outpoint Bernard early yep
but then Bernard comes back later in his
career and really kind of like shot Roy
down yeah and showed like when the
athleticism starts to slip away a little
bit Roy is normal he's a human either
you yeah whereas Bernard was still this
incredibly disciplined very well
schooled boxer it was a real good lesson
for fighters to see the deal like this
is why you use the fundamentals this is
why you fight correctly you can get away
with being Roy Jones jr. but Roy Jones
jr. with his physical gifts I feel like
he could have got away with fighting
discipline too he could have got away
with fighting technically but you know
he just chose to fight his way mm-hmm it
worked for a long time until it didn't
work but it worked better than anybody I
mean it was amazing to watch in the day
when he was on top yeah you know when he
was knocking out Virgil Hill with body
shots and putting his hands behind his
back and knocking dudes out I mean that
was the guy fell in love with you know
but he could have could have he could
have gone and had a full career and rode
off in the sunset and been in Pensacola
fishing hunting doing whatever he does
and still not really been super
fundamentally sound but I mean after he
beat John Ruiz for the heavyweight
championship of the world and I had been
going to multiple Roy's fights leading
up to that heavyweight fight Antonio
Tarver who I have a lot of respect for
you know they were rivals in Florida
when they were young
antonio was following roy around trying
to get him to notice i'm trying to get
him to take a fight and I remember clear
as day in the post-fight press
conference after Roy became the
heavyweight champion of the world after
being the middleweight champion starting
at 160 Terra Antonio Tarver interrupted
the press conference he said Roy Jones
you conducted me you've been running
he's going on and on and on Roy looks at
Tarver and and gives him the attention
that he's been after and he said huh he
said I'm a whoop you i'm a whoop you we
gonna make that fight happen and at that
moment I'm thinking like no Roy like no
don't do you're the heavyweight champion
of the world harvard was still light
heavyweight and sure enough right went
down stripped off 25 pounds of muscle
that he had built up with Mac ISIL stone
to get ready for the heavyweight fight
went down there far too close fight but
he didn't look like himself took the
rematch now even after the first fight
with Harvard man you run for the hills
you know what I beat him I wasn't myself
I'm going back up took the rematch and
then got knocked out yeah I didn't
that's where I thought to read the first
fight was earlier now my brain scrambled
here because I thought that that was
immediately after the ruies fight that
he got knocked out yeah it was he went
back down yes
so Ruiz light heavyweight went down
fought over the first time they fought
the rematch they got knocked out so they
fought two times in a row they fought
two times in a row and then they ended
up fighting a third time like waiting on
the road did they really I didn't even
know they fought a third time in Florida
the loss of the weight was a terrible
idea and also let's be realistic about
how he put that weight on is most likely
though some Mexican supplements involved
and if they are gonna put that bulk on
you know I mean I don't know yeah Roy
Jones one of my heroes there's not
disrespect no I hear you but and I've
heard people say stuff like that but
like um that's my guy like I'm a kid so
I'm like not yet I know I get it
I'm believing that it was just raw
Mackie shield stone and hard work I will
leave it at that
it's possible it's possible but I mean
what is he like he was like 33 34th he
was somewhere on it yeah very hard to
put 25 pounds of muscle on hey well it
didn't really cut weight to make the
light heavyweight limit right so you got
to think he was probably like 185 190
probably yeah and so we really only gain
maybe 1015 pounds
still he was lean as [ __ ] he was pretty
lame it seems to take though - Roy had
it no I had that kind of bill oh he was
strong yeah very muscular I mean he had
crazy biceps and no tribe tips yeah it
was all just was weird right he had a
crazy body
I didn't notice dude his body was very
unusual the way he was built like he was
all biceps it was just whipping you know
he's just from whippin punches we don't
use 20 shots ya know he was phenomenal
you got a picture of him Jamie yeah
that's my guy no I listen I'm a gigantic
Roy Jones jr. fan but I mean I feel like
like that's there's one example right
there you see how gigantic his biceps
are but you see it almost more while
he's fighting I mean really had like a
body built to hook you know yeah what if
Jones remained a heavyweight
I mean look he was so goddamn fast as I
mean John Ruiz just was within a tear in
that fight well his thing about the
after the Ruiz fight is you know we had
the same manager James Prince there was
a Tyson fight on the table and I believe
I'm accurate when I say this it was
somewhere around 40 million guaranteed
whoa there's an upside to you stay at
heavyweight keep the weight on it Tyson
wasn't quite Tyson at that time we're
still dangerous but wasn't quite Tyson I
think they were working toward it from
what I've heard Roy wanted more money
James Prince was like bro take this 40
million there's going to be an upside as
you and Mike Tyson Roy Jones of Mike
Tyson Roy somehow said nope the fight
will be there later on down the road put
his attention toward Antonio Tarver the
rest is history
Wow I'm kind of glad in fact I see I
wanted to see him fight Tyson the ride
off in a sense a uno mas one more way
out yeah but I don't think he would have
written I don't think Roy was ever
really gonna ride off in the sunset he
likes me Roy Jones jr. Mike Tyson Jones
had 2003 fight card
mm see is that what around when he
fought Galata there was
start an HBO pay-per-view and they were
supposed to be the first fight on it